now i want to bring in christina raffini
who has been doing terrific work here on
the border for more than a week now uh
tell us about what you've seen and how
what we're looking at now is different
one of the things none of this was here
when we got here we got here the day
after the russian bombardment and there
was absolutely nothing here there was
one older woman a polish woman in a shop
giving out tea just out of her out of
her own pocket to people there was no
support system and there was just a
flood of people coming over the border
same is what you're seeing now lots of
women and children on their own who've
been walking for miles it is absolutely
freezing out here i don't have to tell
you that and every time i see them i
just can't think about you know how
these little kids have been out here in
the cold so long but the next day we
came back and people were putting up
tents they were people giving out cell
phones there were people giving out
meals and the response we've seen from
from the polish people and from people
all over europe we were at a bus station
where people had driven overnight from
germany and they were holding up signs
with different destinations all over
germany offering housing offering jobs
one man said it was it was some of the
worst days of his family's life getting
out of ukraine but when they got here
almost all their problems were over
because almost everything they needed
was given to them upon arrival now the
other thing i have noticed is it does
come in waves the first day people were
looking more and more just exhausted but
lately i think for the first time we're
starting to see real fear on people's
faces because so many people here in
poland didn't believe it could get to
this and the same for the ukrainians
christina thank you very much we
appreciate your coverage
and gail and nate as i send it back to
you it's important to remember that the
people here have so much need much of it
is provided for but after walking for
miles for hours sometimes for days i'll
say that what people want most is often
just a chair to sit down there was one
woman i talked to who had been on her
feet for 15 hours straight with her two
children before she finally found relief
and safety here in poland
yeah you know tony you and christina
touched on it i can't imagine what it's
like in those
in that circumstance under the best of
conditions but when you talk about the
freezing cold how cold is it there i
mean it just looks mixed it is add this
weather on top of what you're dealing
with
yeah it is bitterly
biting cold and it is windy it has been
spitting snow
all day
parents here hurry to feed their kids
the hot soup that's provided because it
too will go cold so the elements are yet
another thing to battle here in poland
well you got me with the dinosaur hat
and barbie because we can all relate to
that i don't care where you live you
know the universal symbol of what that
means to children thank you very much
tony